did they employ you or whoever it was
because they were a woman or because
they were qualified
um I feel like they employed
employed me myself because they needed
someone to be like off that level of you
know experience in Calabar in their
establishment and they had a lot of male
counterparts already so they wanted to
even out and obviously I'm black and you
know the high rock you know you have to
have like gender fluid was it to fill a
quota I feel like yeah there was making
you know filling out the stuff but at
the same time they needed it to be in
the hierarchy they already had a male
one so it was like to even out but like
I said them giving me that position for
me felt like okay they're trying to make
it more fluid to the other ladies there
that okay you know it's possible because
I feel like before they employed me they
were someone that they could have given
it in like you know pay rise they could
have gave them a you know a little job
rise whatever but they didn't they put a
new person there so at times yeah I feel
like women are being given extra you
know position but just I'll be being
trusted with the position that we've
been given okay